(music)
Javier Alejandro Masis:
Welcome to Princeton.
(music)
Jean-Philippe Jabre:
My favorite class was probably Econ 101.
Solomon Braun:
Intro to Psychology.
Rund Abdelfatah:
Introduction to Anthropology.
An-Ting Liu:
The seminar in Ghana.
Ayomikun Okeowo:
Computer science.
I like it because you get to make whatever types
Ayomikun Okeowo:
of program you want.
James Thorman:
One was a class called "Economics and Public Policy,"
taught by Professor Bogan, and the other one was a "High-Tech
James Thorman:
Entrepreneurship" course taught by Ed Zschau.
Neha Goel:
Human rights with Professor Gary Bass.
It was just amazing class.
Rivka Cohen:
It's tied between Arabic and philosophy --
"Intro to Metaphysics and Epistemology."
Javier Alejandro Masis:
I was in a class called "Music of the Americas."
Nene Umoren:
"Japanese Pop Culture in the Age of Globalization."
Sonya Chu:
"Physics 105," which is general physics, but it's the
advanced, the honors course.
Ukachi Emeruwa:
I got to go to Ghana up for my global
health certificate.
Hannah McDonald-Moniz:
I got to take a class over the summer abroad in Italy
with a small group of people, and it was the best way to
Hannah McDonald-Moniz:
learn Italian in a very short amount of time.
It was an intensive class in four weeks that took up
Hannah McDonald-Moniz:
the spot of one semester. And then the next summer I
got to go to Paris for an internship, and then I
Hannah McDonald-Moniz:
also was able to research my senior thesis in Italy.
Elizabeth Stevens:
I would say one of the best academic experiences I've
had here at Princeton is the flexibility in their allowing
Elizabeth Stevens:
me to pursue the academics that I want to do.
I am an independent major in biological anthropology,
Elizabeth Stevens:
which is almost a double major in the anthropology
and EEB departments.
(music)
Raphael Frankfurter:
I was actually approached by the professor in
the second month of the class and told that he would fund me
Raphael Frankfurter:
doing an internship anywhere in the country relating
to medical anthropology.
Rund Abdelfatah:
It was a first anthropology class I've ever
taken in my life, but I actually fell in love with it,
Rund Abdelfatah:
and I found that I just was really passionate about the
subject area, and I've actually decided that I may
Rund Abdelfatah:
be an anthropology major because of that class.
Sonya Chu:
But overall, I was really happy I did that
class because it was the most challenging class
Sonya Chu:
I've ever done so far.
Rivka Cohen:
Arabic can be a very difficult language, especially
grammatically, and we have a lot of fun in that class.
James Thorman:
Merging economics and public policy was a very
interesting exercise that kind of enabled me to think about
James Thorman:
applying economics in a way I hadn't thought about before,
and actually became the basis for kind of what
James Thorman:
I would study later on.
Neha Goel:
We got to learn about just the development of human
rights as a concept in general, and I learned a lot of things
Neha Goel:
that I didn't even expect, like the fact that people disagree
with the idea of human rights at a very basic level, the
Neha Goel:
very validity of the concept.
Jean-Philippe Jabre:
I mean, it really helped to understand the recent
recessions, and now I'm definitely planning on majoring
Jean-Philippe Jabre:
in econ just because of that class is a great class, great lecturer.
Nene Umoren:
We're talking about themes that are relevant,
things that are popping up in our everyday lives, and looking
Nene Umoren:
at it from a totally different perspective of seeing how other
students view the world around us.
Neha Goel:
I definitely found myself opening my eyes and
learning something completely new.
Rund Abdelfatah:
You can find great things in unexpected places.
Sonya Chu:
Definitely take challenging courses because
they're well worth it.
Rivka Cohen:
I felt that I learned how to organize my thoughts in
a completely different way.
Javier Alejandro Masis:
It's just much more interesting to see how things
work than to immediately label them as good or bad.
An-Ting Liu:
I did not expect it to be such an interesting and
life-changing experience.
Sonya Chu:
It's not just about getting the top grades, it's
about learning something and challenge yourself.
Javier Alejandro Masis:
That's probably the 'aha' moment.
(music)
Ukachi Emeruwa:
Besides having an extremely flexible class
schedule such that I have time for basketball, dance, all the
Ukachi Emeruwa:
kinds of activities I want to do, Princeton also allows
within your course work for amazing opportunities.
Elizabeth Stevens:
Princeton has allowed me to design my own curriculum
and combine the courses that Princeton offers, as well as
Elizabeth Stevens:
mix my advisors between the departments.
Hannah McDonald-Moniz:
For anyone who's interested in languages or
studying abroad, I was really impressed with the number of
Hannah McDonald-Moniz:
unexpected opportunities that I had here at Princeton.
Nene Umoren:
Being able to share in that opportunity, get the broad
range of perspectives that Princeton offers is something that
Nene Umoren:
has been really phenomenal for me, and something that I
wouldn't get anywhere else.
Elizabeth Stevens:
It's allowed me to pursue what I've wanted to do basically my whole life.
Sonya Chu:
Even if it looks like it's impossible, you try your best
and you'd be surprised at what you can achieve.
Ukachi Emeruwa:
I'm forever grateful for having that opportunity.
An-Ting Liu:
This is really a great place to be.
(music)